yeah so i saw the matrix resurrections
again for the second time i can't do
that voice the entire time but i did see
the matrix resurrections again i saw it
online i saw it on hbo max when it came
out so i could skip through the boring
scenes i've been watching it a second
time did it get any better well
well first of all i am going to give you
a spoiler warning i don't even know if
this i'm going to title this spoiler
talk maybe just title it i saw the
matrix resurrections for a second time i
don't know regardless i am going to talk
about more spoilerish stuff that i
couldn't talk about in my spoiler-free
review so you've been warned also i
promise
i will not use the term meta at all in
this video you've heard it enough
you don't need to hear it ever again if
you hear it
in three lifetimes it's it'll be too
soon but i will say upon second viewing
it was interesting to see those concepts
i mean granted i saw them in the first
viewing but it's those moments where you
see something there you're like i felt
like this movie started out as an
interesting concept probably a back and
forth between the wachowskis back in
2003 is like if we were gonna do matrix
four what would we do they both amicably
decided on the smart choice which was
there is no matrix four it's a trilogy
and it's done but
here we are but this movie does start
out with an interesting concept i won't
lie i was the most engaged with the
matrix resurrections at the prospect of
everything we saw in the original
trilogy being a video game i don't know
if that was the way it was maybe it
would have pissed me off but it was a
thing where i was like whoa this looks
bold
let's see where this goes let's see
where this train takes us not like bad
cgi train but you know plot train but
then the movie just kept going and wound
up with its head up its own abs this
movie felt like you ever bounce ideas
off of someone maybe you're talking
philosophy i don't know maybe you're
super stoned you know when someone talks
and at first you're like oh you got
something here all right let's see what
you have to say and then they just keep
talking you're like oh no you're just
you're just making [ __ ] up that's what
this movie felt like to me it's a thing
that actually the matrix sequels do
suffer from the first matrix is i think
flawless it's an imaginative telling
that's self-contained they probably
didn't think they were gonna get sequels
so it works in that self-contained way
it's created to be so it's all right
they need to make a trilogy so they add
things to the lore they do a couple
retcons i say retcons because you know
the first matrix they were like oh emp
it's the only thing we have against the
machines also we have mechs and very big
guns you know that exists too forgot to
mention that so the wachowskis have
always just pulled things out of thin
air it causes the audience at least
myself to be like wait a minute wait
what what doesn't change the fact that
the matrix resurrection started out with
some interesting concepts on the table
one thing i did like is the neil patrick
harris dynamic i didn't like everything
about the guy like when you're looking
at him and comparing him to colonel
sanders you're like well
you are a step back i like the original
architect the way the guy talked you
could tell you're like yeah you are
above human beings neil patrick harris's
character looks like he's taken over as
the new architect he keeps talking about
my predecessor and he was all about
precision he didn't like human nature so
it looks like he's the new guy but he
also doesn't have that commanding
presence you know he talks and acts like
he's a product of the matrix we've gone
from colonel's original recipe to spicy
he does have a great monologue that
monologue he has about human nature and
how feelings supersede facts and the
only reality people are concerned with
is the one that we create up there i was
like this is
true i don't know if it's trying to go
for that thing it's like a villain said
it you're not supposed to agree but i
totally and completely 150
do agree so i don't know what to say
it's like when the joker talks about
things going according to plan i'm like
well he's not wrong i like it when
villains see more clearly in movies than
the heroes and i thought that monologue
was
i thought that was as real as it gets
the i o stuff drags on you see some neat
things about how machines and humans
have worked together absolutely but the
movie undeniably slows down to the point
where i know for a fact you don't want
to hear me talk about it so we're going
to move on it's actually neat to see
jada pinkett smith's character back
niobe because whenever i see an old
character that used to be a young
character there's decades in between and
was like what happened with them you
made strawberries that's cool i wonder
if the strawberries tasted like
strawberries in the matrix though you
think about that that's the thing that
the first matrix also did that this this
movie didn't do
is that it had a great thought a great
thought experiment
broken down in a very simple way how did
the machines know what tasty wheat
tasted like maybe they didn't know what
to make chicken taste like which is why
chicken tastes like everything i'm i was
always pissed that he got hush like
mouse shut up i was like wait the kid's
got a point let's hear him out i always
liked that argument it would have been
kind of cool to go the next step with
this maybe the strawberry tasted like a
strawberry but not exactly like it
tasted like strawberry ish maybe a
little off i get that you know they're
working with the machines the machines
are probably like yeah this is created
from the data from the matrix so it's
gonna taste the same
maybe not exactly no copy is identical
maybe it takes a little off but we'll
never know officially monologued too
much about strawberries but they are an
excellent source of fiber the thing in
this movie that was blatant nostalgia
bay that was in this movie for no reason
other than nostalgia was the merrell
vinjian hey i like the merv as much as
the next guy best part of the matrix
sequels absolutely is why i say it but
he clocks into this movie for about a
minute and a half for nothing having him
in this movie did nothing for the plot
might as well have just had him come in
and be like
remember having him in here was just
absolutely shoehorned in and it was the
epitome of member barry also merovingian
sounded like skeletor in this movie yeah
he-man it's a four maybe they'll have
him in the second
fifth one maybe they'll have him back
and he won't look like he just escaped
from [ __ ] jumanji but the biggest
thing about this movie that stands out
it's not only some of the cgi you're
like that's the best you got the matrix
that had a vision that's that's why bad
cgi and bad choreography in this movie
are such a letdown they hit so much
harder than other movies that have those
problems because the matrix was a vision
that had to create new technology to get
the job done to have that vision on
screen you can't go from that kind of
filmmaking to some basic ass [ __ ] like
this you can
but it's a letdown you think of the
other matrix movies how would they have
made
a character look if they were getting
disoriented and things started to get
euphoric do you think they would have
done some basic ass choppy frame rate
1995 effect like they did in the matrix
resurrections because they did in the
matrix resurrections that's kind of what
this movie felt like actually now that i
mentioned it it does feel like a matrix
fan film at a point this movie felt like
a matrix parody and the martial arts
martial arts and matrix
it's a it's such a great and wonderful
marriage i would say that's a better
love story than trinity and neo it's the
matrix and martial arts the matrix has
always been this aggregate this
amalgamation of genres that defied genre
it's sci-fi it's gun fighting it's
martial arts the martial arts is
definitely a flavor of the matrix and
those martial arts fights and the other
matrix movies they were so clean they
were buttery smooth the fighting in this
movie
it didn't feel like martial arts there
were fights yeah but they didn't feel
like martial arts flavor in this movie
it didn't feel like a martial arts
segment unlike the other matrix movies
which absolutely flawlessly blended that
vibe the ballet of gun fighting and
martial arts fights that were in the
other matrix movies completely gone in
the matrix resurrection this just felt
like basic 2021 choppy fighting
it was like whatever and that's a loss
that keeps this movie from feeling like
a proper matrix movie to me and in the
end neo is the one
of two neo and trinity they have this
bond they they complete a circuit so to
speak they're like a yin and yang neo's
the yin to many people's yangs in the
matrix universe smith trinity's it's the
way he is he's like yeah i just complete
people what can i say so in the end yeah
they jump off the roof and trinity is
actually the one holding neo neil's like
i'm not doing this
are you doing this and then trinity
flies off with neo signaling the end of
this
action sequence that's pretty
forgettable so now after trinity
remembers who she is she has the power
of the one neo has the power of the one
and she has the power of the one they're
both the ones which i guess individually
makes them each the 0.5 she goes to nph
and she can kill them and then bring
them back to life they're both matrix
gods now point is at the end they fly
off past the camera they're both going
to become matrix gods which is kind of
how it ended with neo which means it
won't end here though it could it's
going to be more to tell that they want
to show this movie to me it's not
completely terrible it's just a messy
convoluted piece of 2021 hollywood it's
it's absolutely what you would expect
from modern hollywood a soulless cash
grab built on the back of a greater film
i mean this movie does ironically
address the entertainment industry's
tendency to force creators to make a
sequel against their will four sequels
happens all the time neo has a dialogue
in here where the dude's like well
warner brothers they're forcing us to
make a fourth matrix with or without us
is going to happen i don't know if
that's a dialogue that happened with
lana wachowski or both of the wachowskis
i don't know but in a world where
artists pull from what they know
what is one to assume in that i feel bad
if it did like that sucks you know it
sucks to be in a position where it's
like i have no inspiration to make
something but the studio's kind of
making it happen so i guess i have to do
it admittedly it's what this movie ended
up feeling like so that's it that's my
take don't hate this movie more than any
movie in the history of movies but it is
incredibly disappointing which just it
makes me sad it's meh it's that's the
name of it the matrix
that was a total dead joke i'm so sorry
i'm allowed a dad joke to close out the
year 2021 but the matrix resurrections
again have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
least favorite parts what'd you like
about it what didn't you like about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you